>>> THEY'RE READY FOR YOU.
♪♪
>> THREE, TWO, ONE.
AND WE'RE LIVE.
>> HAVE YOU GUYS HEARD OF THIS
TIKTOK THING?
THE ONLY TIKTOK I HEAR IS MY
BIOLOGICAL CLOCK.
DON'T GET ME STARTED.
DON'T EVEN GET ME STARTED.
>> JEANNIE DARCY, SELECTIVE
STARTAGE.
>> NO ONE BRINGS IT LIKE JEANNIE
DARCY, AND THIS TIME THE
DARCINATOR IS LIVE, WHICH MEANS
YOU'RE HEARING HER JOKES AT THE
SAME TIME SHE'S TELLING THEM,
INSTEAD OF STREAMING IT LATER,
WHICH IS THE REASON MOST PEOPLE
GET NETFLIX.
>> I HAD A BRA FITTING THE OTHER
DAY.
I TRIED ONE ON AND HAD A FIT.
MEN MUST DESIGN THESE THINGS.
HAS ANYONE EVER SEEN A JOCK
STRAP WITH UNDERWIRE?
AM I RIGHT, LADY FRIENDS?
YOU GET MY 411?
DO NOT EVEN THINK OF GETTING ME
STARTED.
>> JEANNIE DARCY IS A LEGEND.
THAT GIRL INSPIRED A WHOLE
GENERATION OF LESBIAN COMEDIANS.
>> SHE'S NOT A LESBIAN.
>> SAY WHAT NOW?
>> JEANNIE DARCY TAKES NO
PRISONERS.
>> MY FRIEND GOT A DOG AND
ALWAYS COMPLAINS HE MESSES UP
HER HOUSE AND JUMPS IN HER BED.
I SAID, ARE YOU SURE IT'S A DOG,
OR IS IT MY EX-HUSBAND?
WHO'S WITH ME?
DON'T GET ME STARTED.
DON'T EVEN GET ME STARTED.
>> OH, MY GOD.
JEANNIE IS AWESOME.
SHE EVEN GAVE ME HER SET LIST.
>> I PICKED UP ONE OF THOSE NEW
TESLA ELECTRIC CARS.
I COULDN'T GET IT STARTED.
DON'T GET ME STARTED.
>> JEANNIE DARCY, SELECTIVE
STARTAGE, STREAMING LIVE
TONIGHT.
>> DON'T EVEN GET ME STARTED.